[Music]
all right yesterday we mentioned that
the Golden State Warriors are the first
team to win the first two games the NBA
Finals by scoring 120 or more points
since the 1987 Lakers who went
back-to-back in such fashion against the
Boston Celtics back then
including a 141 point game in Game two
and the leading scorer of that game was
not Kareem not magic not worthy but the
man to my right Byron Scott you're on
the Rich Eisen show yours good to see I
didn't know that did you not know I did
not I don't remember that I just so when
you were saying I was like okay where's
he going with this where you going with
you scored 20 for that night Wow magic
at 22 and 20 20 assists that night that
sounds about normal pretty close to it
so what the Warriors are doing right now
and people are calling all time great so
I'm talking to somebody of with from one
of the all-time great teams what do you
think when you hear that about the
current Warriors being said that about
the Warriors just a great basketball
team you know you look at them watch
them play they played a game I think the
right way they play for each other they
played a win they don't care about the
individual statistics or accolades you
know a Steve Kerr you got to give a lot
of credit to as far as doing a great job
of being able to deal with the Eagles
that come along with being a great NBA
player and having a great team so you
know all those guys are in it for the
right reasons just like we were in 87 I
mean we you know Magic Johnson was
unbelievable you know he could have led
us and scoring every year if he wanted
to
same with Kareem and James Worthy but
everybody I was was willing to sacrifice
for the betterment of the team and when
you look at the Golden State Warriors I
think the one guy who has sacrificed the
most has been klay Thompson you know
soon as they got Kevin Durant he took a
back seat sort of speak and it was all
because he still wanted to win you know
so I loved watching them play I love
what they're doing they're a great team
it's gonna always be a conversation on
who's the greatest team of all times and
I know our team is gonna always be
mentioned and I'm biased I still think
we had the greatest team that ever
played the game but there it's great to
have those type of debates so yeah I
mean we ain't because we discussed this
also with BJ Armstrong yester
he's the agent of draymond Green and
obviously played with one of the
all-time greats if not the greatest of
all time in terms of arguments with
Michael Jordan hee hee the disease of
Moore which is Pat Riley's phrase that
that's what tears teams asunder and that
does not appear to be hurting this team
right now in Golden State do you see how
does that get communicated how did Riley
communicate that to you how is Kurt
doing what he is doing right now with
all of these egos in the 21st so I think
the first thing you got to do as a coach
rich is be able to fence your best
player that this is the best thing for
everybody you know let's win as many
championships as we can while we're
together you know hopefully we can keep
the core guys together and that's what
we did in Los Angeles Pat was great
you know we're keeping our top eight
guys together for as long as we can and
you know it could and then you're
obviously age catches up to you and then
you got a team like Chicago who came
along at the right time as well so
everybody again has to be willing to
give a little bit of sacrifice a little
bit of their game you know to be able to
keep this run going I remember I having
a conversation with a really good friend
of mine who you know extremely well run
a lot when he was in San Francisco
playing and we were renting
championships and he asked the same
question you know and I said listen
we're trying to win as many
championships as we can while we're
together because we know you know time
is gonna catch up to it's just like a
will Golden State eventually but they're
a lot younger
you know then we were at that particular
time so you just have to have guys who
are willing to sacrifice and I think and
go to the state that's exactly what
we're seeing we see a bunch of guys that
are willing to do that so Byron Scott
here in the red tries to show ronnie
Lott reached out to you and the what
mid-80s ladies ladies mid eighties
because we were just obviously we talked
about Dwight Clark's passing you know
our number one quite a bit going down
that memory lane of that starting the
dynastic Bill Walsh era and it's
fascinating to me that somebody from the
Bill Walsh team in the middle of that
reaches out to you to say how do you do
this yeah cuz we Ronnie and I had known
each other since college days you know
and Marcus Marcus Allen as well you know
so we were just out one summer and he
was
your pac-12 date when I first got you
know we are attracted to our
conversation right so it was a great
conversation and we had just won I think
in 85 and the conversation was looking
we're trying to win as many
championships as we can and we're gonna
try to keep the core guys together and
we have an unbelievable leader in Magic
Johnson who wants to just win and that
just kept us going and then all of a
sudden you saw 49ers you know starting
to win and and I think Ronny mentioned
it in a Sports Illustrated story that
you know I talked to you know be Scott
and this is how the Lakers are looking
at you know life in general as far as
basketballs concerned let's just keep
winning as many as you can everything
else to take care of yourself what do
you think LeBron James is thinking today
what's going between his temples Barnes
I think as great as he is he still
probably looks back at Game one as a
tremendously blown opportunity but I
also think with his greatness that he's
probably tried to put that away as soon
as possible and understand that listen
we have to come home and take care of
home we have to take care of business
here just like we did against Boston now
this is a different animal that they're
facing you know didn't the Celtics
obviously but I think he you know I mean
watching that tape just watching him at
the end of the game you know just sit
there put his hands in his I mean put
his face in his hands I think that was
you know telling me at least that man we
blew it yeah we had a golden opportunity
to come in here and still game one and
we blew it but with all that being said
rich he still knows it we got to put
that in the past and we got to come out
here and we got a whole serve at home
just like we did the last series and if
we do that didn't this is a series no
doubt what do you say to people who
think he should have done that in real
time in the moment with his head in his
hands realizing okay my teammate had a
shot in the middle of the paint with
four seconds to go for us when it
thought that we were tied dribbled it
out we had a timeout left nobody called
it right what do you say to those who
think he should have even with all that
in between his temples at that moment
time should have been in real-time
turned the page and God's faces and
rally the truth yeah you know again you
dealing with such an emotional
high and low when you're dealing with
sports and I think people have to
understand that at that time in that
moment you know what you saw was real
that was just the way he felt at that
particular time so for you to say that
he should have did this he should have
did that
you know everybody's different I think
Magic Johnson would have done that you
know what happened I think he would have
came up to say if I dribbled it out Heda
came up to me in the huddle before the
timeout was was over before tyronn lue
came into the huddle and he was said be
it's all right we still right here we
still got a chance to win now I don't
know what MJ would have done you know
and we saw what LeBron did you know so
it's just hard to say because
everybody's so different and everybody
takes that information in and processes
it differently as well so at that
particular time that's how he felt in my
mind when you saw his head go down into
his hands he's like we just blew it and
he probably probably didn't want to say
anything anybody he was just kind of
processing in in his head and you got it
you got to respect that
well I respect the fact that he didn't
after the game was over when he's at the
press conference he was clearly
swallowing his tongue and avoiding the
situation best he could to not throw jr.
right under a boss right which I also
couldn't so when in your history of
being a coach as you were for 15 NBA
season and a player as you were for 14
NBA seasons and then in Arizona State
for for collegiate seasons on I mean I
won't even go out even go back to when
you were a kid have you ever seen
somebody did not know what the score was
at the end of the game um you have to
think of yeah you know you're talking
about 37 years of it right I think I
have but I can't remember witnessing
anything like that especially to score I
mean you can you can understand some
time to time the 24-second shot gets
away from you thought you had a little
bit more time on the clock but the score
you know when you walk out on the court
after any timeout you know or any dead
ball situation almost one of the first
things you do rich as a players you kind
of look up to see what the score is
you also look up to see how much times
you know is on the shot clock
so
I'm sure I have but I can't remember you
know being in a game or witnessing the
game where guy didn't know what the
score was
Byron Scott here on the Rich Eisen show
we'll take a 60-second break come back
and we'll talk strategy for Game three
and what you think can be done or should
be done by the Cavs to try and get one
on the board
that's what Byron Scott at official
underscore B Scott on Twitter we're back
with Byron in a moment believe it or not
1991 on this date in 1991 that was the
moment in the NBA Finals where Michael
went out for what appeared to be a right
handed slam and when he realized that
there was nothing home there he switched
to his left hand and went off glass to
take down the Lakers in 1991 you sir
Byron Scott were on the bench for that
play correct yes I was so what we what
were you guys thinking when you see
Michael sending like this you know you
thought he was gonna dunk it and I think
he saw saying Perkins kind of you know
coming to his vision and figured he has
to change it up and you just kind of go
wow you know the guy was different you
know that right away and I think he was
evolving as a basketball player and it
was his time did you say this is a
changing in the garden not at that
particular time I think after the series
was over you know there was a little bit
of a changing of the guard that that
team was they were hungry they were
young and they had a superstar and
Michael Jordan had another great player
and Scottie Pippen you know Horace Grant
and those other guys were just really
solid BJ I'm strong like mr. John Paxson
I mean they just had a really good solid
basketball team and didn't add too great
Phil Jackson as well was there a true
animus with you and the Celtics like a
true animus like you genuinely did not
like those guys in green yeah and it
lasted for a long time you know I mean
to the point where subject Maxwell
cornbread cornbread games now you doing
the games and he was also doing a radio
show before every game and all I guess
all the coaches from the opposite team
would come in and he would interview two
coaches for his pregame and I'm coaching
New Jersey so I'm not too far removed
from not you know having that that
hatred that I had for the Celtics and
our guy but marks who was our PR guy in
New Jersey says
coach coach Cedric cornbread wants to
come in and interview you and I looked
him straight down I said hail no serious
coach I said I'm not talking to him
and that was my rookie year as a coach
you know but that's that's the year 2000
run I mean you're not too far removed I
mean like 10 years least right I
couldn't do it
it took me till the next year but Bobby
said coach please he talks he talks to
every coach before the game you gotta at
least talk to him I said I don't have to
do you know what and then I finally said
okay I'll talk to him when he came in
the room I still had that you know I'm
gonna stand here and you know talk to
him but I'm not gonna like this I'm not
gonna enjoy it but when we finished the
interview and we talked for about five
or six more minutes and all of a sudden
I was like you know what being a bad guy
you know he's not bad and then I talked
to Danny you know a few few months or a
few months ago you know later and then I
saw you know lb and and all sudden I
started realizing that you know the
reason I hated these guys is because
they were just like us in a sense of
they just wanted to win they didn't care
about who got the glory they didn't care
about the individual accolades they just
wanted to win championships they just
did it in a different way you know so
then I had respect for him back in back
in the day but I had more respect
afterwards because I really got to know
them as people and it was it was kind of
cool after that so I don't have I don't
harvest that that anger anymore rich
well I do
Byron have a mandate as a somebody in
this chair to ask you if there is one
person from the Celtics teams where you
still do have that little bit of
resentment for I don't I don't not
McHale no no Kevin and I coached against
each other for a number of years when he
was at Houston I was at New Orleans and
not Danny which would be the obvious
pick you know no I don't work R as a
Knick fan him with that towel cool with
the towel yeah he did score one point
two rebounds if that
but look I mean I've seen ml in the past
six months I've talked to ml on the
phone everything I'm good we're good
that's good is that missing from today's
game today yes
I truly believe you you don't have those
type of rivalries anymore because all
these guys grew up in the air where they
play a you ball together they play on
these traveling teams so they get to
know each other from their age of nine
ten years old until they get drafted in
the NBA so I don't think they harvest
that type of feelings when they're with
an organization like the Los Angeles
Lakers order Boston Celtic would have
which has so much history against one
another you know so when I came in the
lead I I inherited that that's feeling
because you know the guys I was playing
with and the guys who played with that
Laker
you know purple and gold jersey going
before me to Jerry whistles and the
world Chamberlain's and Miguel Goodrich
is the guys of that nature you know who
couldn't stand the Celtics so it was
just like that's how I was you know it's
how it's supposed to be well what do you
say Barnes got to people who say well
don't criticize the Warriors for being a
super team take a look at those Celtics
take a look at the 80s Lakers they were
super team do you agree with that
assessment yeah I do I don't criticize
you know I didn't criticize Kevin Durant
when he wanted to go to Golden State you
know I I personally wanted him to stay
at OKC but why is that I just thought
that they had a great chance to beat to
go to state warriors and I was you know
like why would you want to join them
instead of beat them you know back in
her magic Johnson wouldn't join Larry
Bird
he wouldn't join Michael Jordan and vice
versa you know they wanted to beat each
other you know so that was my only take
on it you know but when he decided to go
I was like listen that the man is his
own guy he's gonna make decisions that's
based on what's best for him and I and I
and I respect that
do you think LeBron is coming here I'm
hoping I'm hoping rich you know I it's
two places for me you see the LA or stay
in Cleveland really yes
what about Philadelphia I don't want him
yeah and I mean if he does is obviously
I'm thinking more of a selfish reason I
don't want him to be I don't want his
legacy to be where he's jumped
team to team the team you know seeking
championships I really feel is great to
see his guys should come to him not him
go to them you know so okay but I'm
coming here to the lake that would be
well I mean you can't see he's chasing
Championships because the team so young
here he would have to be part of a a
couple of seasons one things despite his
goat nasai and even if there is somebody
who joins him like Paul George or
somebody else that might be completely
off the radar mm-hmm but coming here
wouldn't he be just putting trying to
put 23 up against every other number
eight and twenty four eight and twenty
fours to the latest at two of them I
think your point is well-taken
if he comes here and he and it depends
on who you get if it's a Paul George
Kawhi Leonard somebody like that or
boogie cousins I mean it just kind of
depends who fits with him then I agree
which was it might take a year or two
cuz then got to get somebody else to go
along with that group so the core here
in Los Angeles with the youngsters that
they have are developing nicely and if
you can add two pieces like the two that
we just talked about and then the next
year add another one then I think they
have a chance to win a championship
couple more minutes left with Byron
Scott three-time NBA champion again 15
seasons in an end and the NBA head
coaching spot and then 14 seasons in the
NBA as a player what do you think needs
to be done for Game three for Cleveland
here I think first of all they haven't
played Golden State that physical brand
of basketball if they have to play
against Golden State you you got you got
to grab hold bump
hit you know it's my ending the playoffs
at this particular time the referees let
you get a little bit a little weight a
little bit more away with that so I
think in Cleveland we know they've
played really well at home we know that
well we don't know but we're hoping that
a few of those role players really show
up because they do play better at home
because they're more comfortable and
then I think you got to rough them up
you got you got to rough them up I think
you might have to go to a couple of guys
on the bench that you haven't played
played much let's see how about three
words for you activate kendrick perkins
that wouldn't be a bad idea because you
again when you want to rough him up he's
the guy that can rough him up but the
flip side of that of that is when he's
on defense and going to state it's
coming down they're gonna put him in
every single pick-and-roll and there's
no way in this world that he can guard
Steph Curry on a pick-and-roll if they
switch there's no waiting guard Kevin
Durant and in in in klay Thompson you
know so you're gonna have to give up
something ever if you activate him but I
think right now you're throwing the
kitchen sink you got to do whatever it
takes you know you got to exhaust every
opportunity or every player that you
have on that [ __ ] that's available if
somebody doesn't get it going or they're
miss a shot you got to get them out and
bring somebody else in and you got to
see who's gonna join LeBron James in
this quest to win this game because this
is Game seven for them it really is Game
three is Game seven for Cleveland they
lose this game this series is over last
one for you use the word exhaust and
made me think of asking this question
tyloo as we all know how to take a break
this year right right talking about
losing sleep losing just me wasn't
eating right you spent all those years
as an NBA head coach can you relate to
that yeah yeah I mean you wake up in the
middle of the night you know think about
the game did you just had adjustments
that you probably should have made or
that you didn't make that you could have
made what are you gonna do the next day
in the film session you know how are you
gonna approach a team I mean all those
things you know keep you up at night you
know now you got to think about your
opponent as well so I can obviously
relate to what ty went through this
season and I understand it you know
completely and everybody thinks that
this job is being such a glamorous job
but when you're in the position that
he's in with the player that he's
coaching the LeBron James one of the
greatest of all times
it's added pressure on you as a coach
and I don't think we give him enough
credit this is three straight finals
he's been - as a head coach that's
pretty damn good you know I don't care
who's on your team and I know he has one
of the best but you know so he's done a
hell of a job of being able to coach
this team and get him to this level on a
consistent basis for three straight
years and it does wear and tear on you
as
head coach thanks for coming in barn
rich always you know I saw you at the I
saw you at the the charity golf event
for for the Red Cross here in Los
Angeles
you were there and I'm like hey you know
I know we would talk about it so thank
you for being about it my pleasure
I appreciate that I have a back anytime
Byron you got my number and I do
actually good Scott here on the Rich
Eisen show the Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on audience